la nouvelle programmation 2014 2020 est
marquée cette année par des changements
dans la gestion des fonds européens
notamment dans les régions d'outremer
c'est désormais le conseil départemental
qui devient autorités de gestion des
fonds européen agricole pour le
développement rural ont mis les urgences
nous avons donc que le déploiement du
dispositif fait d un ici au niveau local
une donnée par portable puisque comme
vous le savez c'est le conseil des
parcours canal qui va tenter assurer le
rôle d'autorité de gestion du feader
pour regarde bien évidemment de nos
compétences en matière de développement
agricole et rural qui sut de
l'harmonisation date de 2005 entre la
région et le département
et d'autre part dans le cadre de la
gestion partenariale des fonds européens
entre l'état la région et notre
collectivité
le feader 2014 2020 est doté de 385 25
millions d'euros auxquels viennent
s'ajouter 128,5 millions d'euros de
contreparties nationales
une nouvelle gestion encadrée par des
règles très précises à savoir des appels
à projets dans ce cadre qu'un premier
appel à projets a été lancé pour
répondre à une des mesures obligatoires
du cadre européen
le transfert de connaissances et actions
d'information de conseil départemental
autorités de gestion va maintenant
complètement piloter les fonds feader
comme la région pilote le feder l'état
le fse la collectivité départementale à
la compétence pleine et entière sur la
gestion des fonds européens enveloppe de
385 millions d'euros contre partie
nationale comprise sera gérée à travers
des appels à projets aux des appels
d'offres c'est la grande nouveauté je
tirais dans la gestion des fonds
européens
jusqu'à présent les modalités
d'attribution de subventions se faisait
sur simple présentation de dossiers
aujourd'hui les organisations les
organismes agricoles devront répondre
aux différents appels à projets un appel
à projets d'un montant de 31 millions
d'euros qui concerne entre autres
l'encadrement technique des filières
agricoles liées à la canne à sucre
la diversification végétale l'élevage
l'installation des agriculteurs et leur
accompagnement technique des projets la
maîtrise et la gestion du foncier
demandera tout simplement à ces
organismes de s'habituer
je dirais à répondre aux appels à
projets aussi de nous présenter des
projets bien ficelés c'est vrai que le
cadre est porté par là par le
département le cadre est fixé par
l'europe
néanmoins nous allons nous analysé la
viabilité des projets et voir
effectivement s'il n'ya pas redondante
ouvrir aux tendances pendant les
différentes organisations qui vont nous
soumettre ces projets le conseil
départemental qui par ailleurs soutient
la filière agricole avec un budget
annuel de 20 millions d'euros qui
financent dans les compétences
obligatoires la mise en oeuvre de la
politique de protection du foncier
agricole et la remise en valeur agricole
des terres en friche
d'autres actions sont également menées
de manière totalement facultative à
savoir le développement de la production
locale de qualité avec par exemple les
marchés pays du département oeuvre
également depuis plusieurs années à
l'introduction d'une part plus
importante de produits issus de
l'agriculture locale dans la
restauration scolaire est souhaitable
qu'on puisse développer des filières
locales en en particulier en cultures
maraîchères et qu'on puisse donner à
manger à nos enfants des productions
locales
je pense en particulier aux production
de grains verts avec deux pays sauf que
ben il faut une fédé organisée
au départ il faut de les agriculteurs et
puis après il faut des coopératives ou
des sociétés qui puisse organiser la
filière ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement
si je prends l'exemple de la commune de
saint-louis la prison centrale fait 7500
et 8000 repas par jour vous comprendrez
que pouvoir donner des preuves du pays
aux enfants
il faut quand même que en amont il y ait
des structures qui permettent
d'alimenter ses cuisines centrales en
produits locaux
la date limite de remise des dossiers de
candidature pour ce premier appel à
projets est fixée au 30 juin 2015